your favorite thing about working with
Chris nice when we asked that film like
ah he leads by example so much he's like
the first one day the last one to leave
very pregnant
yeah very hands-on yeah I was always
told about like if you was to ever do a
film that you'd hear the directors
shouting the directions from my three
miles away in a tent but you know Chris
is there the whole thing we the camera
and Chris Desmond literally workers hate
it a lot mana
yeah this huge sensing there's kind of
you know real Spitfires and warships all
around you all the rest of it dozens of
extras just about the Lee the scale of
this was absolutely massive general
public you're into like an epic suspense
thriller based within the framework of a
historical background we ran to watch
like a yes or intense just doesn't give
the audience time to think we're just
applying straighten out as world and you
just kind of swept along it which is and
your job taken taken will you see this
world through their eyes and ears and
that story really needs to be told it's
a film art of survival and plant and
panic its breathless I think it can be
pretty brilliant you can practically see
us in here what so
you